tv ratings oscars slump to an
all-time low the hollywood reporter says
the 93rd academy awards drew 10.4
million viewers on sunday
that's a steep drop you ready folks
folks from 23.64 million let me get this
straight
23.64 million people watched the academy
awards last year this year to only 10.4
the 56 percent decline in total viewers
is keeping and though keeping
with those for grammys which well 51
percent golden globe 62 percent
sag awards 52 percent
you think this woke approach is working
golden globes sag
grammys and oscars norm land took home
the coveted best picture award while
anthony hopkins who was asleep
and francis mcdormand won best actor and
actress in the leading role
anthony hopkins i watched your father by
the way i watched him it was an okay
movie he's not
obviously he killed it he typically
kills it no matter what it is
he wins he's asleep they can't even get
a hold of him he wants to sleep because
he thought he wasn't going to win it at
all
okay the guy's knocked out and he wins
and asked her hopkins victory was an
upset over chadwick boseman who died in
august after private four-year battle
with colin cancer boseman was nominated
for best actor for his role in ma
rainey's black bottom this year
uh brought barrier-breaking wins
including the first woman of color to
win best director and best black woman
to win the first black woman to win the
best makeup and hairstyling so
what's the point here here's the point
do you remember when ricky gervais
hosted
oh yeah gosh did he host oh he opened it
i know okay okay
yeah i mean that's what he calls the
famous uh speech but that's a host
okay that was his monologue that he went
up and he says
just when you come up here and you know
thank your agent thank you god take the
trophy and get the
you know and everybody the next day
was talking about this right so i don't
even know why you invited me says oh
here we go let me see oh my gosh let's
start off with this and yes to accept
this
so he went about that brought eyeballs i
watched the oscars because of ricky
gervais i watched it because he was
hilarious right
called everybody i'm not gonna watch it
with jimmy kimmel i'm not gonna watch it
with these you know people going up
there and just giving their same old
rhetoric one after another after another
and just this validates that snl should
be happy because it's probably gonna be
their biggest
one they've had in the last 12 months
we're having this guy and probably the
last time
snl had the most viewership i'm willing
to bet
it's going to be either murphy chappelle
or trump i'm willing to bet it's one of
those openings
so we're going to see what's going to
happen with musk i think snl should be
thankful
snl should be thankful that a guy like
elon musk has agreed to come
i think it's gonna bring eyeballs that
you don't typically get and
as well as the oscars should invite
somebody like him or somebody crazy like
him
to get up and be a host and talk [ __ ] to
everybody because
no like espy's what's the who was the
best espy's host of all time
give some of the best sp's was it drake
drake killed him okay
jake was awesome you know well by the
way you comedy he took a shot at
draymond green's podcast he says it's
sad right peyton manning got up there
and he says you know the swim team uh
you know has done such a great job
matter of fact they're doing such a good
job that kevin durant is thinking about
joining them
the camera went on durant and then it
went on westbrook
but peyton what do we like we like it
when the host is taking shots at the
athletes at the actors
no one wants to watch somebody say how
amazing you are
like you know i get uncomfortable you
know how the whole thing even got
started well let me tell you the event
was great i'm not offended i'd much
rather just go past it
it's the fun part it's the shot part
it's the hey it's this happened that
happened that's what the audience kind
of wants to see right they don't want to
see
you're so amazing you're so great
hollywood show it should be
well you know we kind of saw what
happened there if
what did he say gervais said if isis was
to start a uh
uh a show not a show if isis was to be
the next netflix believe me you'd call
your manager saying let's try to get on
the show
yeah call your agent call your agent to
get on the show there
he took a shot at apple he took a shot
at tim cook he took a shot at everybody
both snl oscars grammys golden globes
they
desperately need to bring back an
entertaining
host who will make fun of them because
that's what america
and the world wants to see however going
back to the vaccine conversation we had
at the beginning
unfortunately there's a community today
that's that not that does not like to
hear
opposing ideas i sent this tweet out
earlier yesterday
went to sleep woke up next thing i know
i'm getting a bunch of private messages
from people
hey pat dude i agree with you i can't
really say anything but i 100 i can't
even tell you the people that message me
dm me okay
i put this tweet out yesterday i said
let's cancel walking on eggshells
let's cancel the inability to entertain
and go posting opposing idea
let's cancel forcing everyone having to
agree with us let's cancel
judging people for a mistake they made
30 years ago let's cancel extreme
sensitivity
let's just respect one another right i
mean what a concept how hard
is that to do what a concept you know
what was the most interesting thing
about this simple concept
people disagreed really people the
people that actually
disagree are the ones that entertain me
the most when you go down and read some
of the ones that
they disagree with by the way for
whatever reason
i mean if you go down and use read some
of these you'll see the disagreements
they make but anyways that's my thoughts
on
oscars what do you think about oscars
being down
56 percent decline much like you and not
oh sorry matt
no no good good and i was just saying
much like you and snl i don't watch the
oscars i i it's just you out of
everybody doesn't watch your head
i'm not you were sitting there with a
notepad and pen ready to take notes
so this is a dumb question the oscars
are for movies is that what it is
okay like i don't watch movies uh
i just don't i don't know why you're not
a movie guy
i used to be when i was a kid i loved
the movies i had my running top ten i
love the movies
i uh i just i just don't watch movies
ever i don't go to the movie theaters
i cancel netflix is that because you
spend most of your time on that website
called only fan
hey guys shout out to my only fans
account check me out on only fans i'm
now accepting donations
sales talks money aka soybean mafia only
fans it's only 19.99 an hour
check me out he shows his chest hair
there's a lot of
that's true that's true i just don't
watch the oscars i don't know but i
would watch it if there was an
entertaining host or some controversy i
would
i'm just not a movie guy but that's my
would you i would watch it
billboard got up and he said couple
things and by the way you know what was
crazy
that bill burr wasn't himself when he
was hosting a couple months ago
even himself wasn't himself he was so
worried a billboard who doesn't give a
crap he was worried about what he's
worried about
he was worried about what's gonna happen
if like i'm walking on eggshells like no
man just let it
make let's go like take take some shots
tell some jokes let's have some fun
let's go through it you know it's got to
be that kind of an environment
that's what happens you know and by the
way a great sales meeting
you know it's a great sales meeting well
that that's what happens
let me tell you what we're going to do
to you can't wait it's that's what
makes it exciting you need a versus you
ever been to an insurance conference
we would like to take this uh moment to
thank
john and mary for a wonderful job they
did this last year with the
um uh with this by the way just me even
acting i guarantee we just lost 100
people
right you go to these insurance
conferences you know these these
conventions they but i'm like put all
the knife away people are going to slip
their risk committing suicide how boring
this thing is right now
now when you host an assurance
conference you also have to tell people
because some people put away their
knives but it's not good because
security pins are thrown around
you should see sapala and ricky aguilar
are going at it i mean
titans i i can't wait for our conference
in in uh at the mgm grand i mean we have
one coming up in may but the one in
august when we have mike tyson on it
he's going to be at our sales guard mike
tyke to see the heat of people let me
tell you what trump said to the oscars
here's what donald trump said to the
oscars donald trump seizes on oscars
low uh uh oscar waiting to bash telecast
he says don't be so politically correct
and boring that's bash deadline
apparently that's called bashing
if you say don't be so politically
correct and boring donald trump's office
emailed the statement to reporters
tuesday
in which the former president bashed the
oscars noting its low ratings and
suggesting
it return a host to the proceedings
and change its name back to academy
awards what used to be called the
academy awards is now called the oscars
a far less important elegant name
had the lowest television rating in
recorded history even much lower than
last year which set
another record off they keep with the
current ridiculous formula it would only
get worse
if that's possible trump said go back 15
years look at the formula they
they then use change the name back to
the academy awards don't be so
politically correct and boring and do it
right
also bring back a great host these
television television people
spend all their time thinking about how
to promote the democratic party which is
destroying our country and cancel
conservatives and republicans
that formula certainly hasn't worked
very well for the academy as president
trump only took
to criticizing the telecast including
last year when he bashed oscar voters
for giving best picture to parasite at a
rally he said to the south uh korean
film
what the hell was that all about we've
got enough problems with south korea
with trade on top of it they give the
best movie of the year to them
was it good i don't know so there you go
even trump had something to say
about the others well shout out to my
wife baby my boo boo sheena
she's a big korean anything
korean dramas korean face mask green
skin products
you know korean barbecue uh and we did
check out parasite it wasn't a good
movie
to to to be able to say you know you
know it warrants the the oscar i didn't
think it was
it was a good movie i don't think it was
an oscar uh a worthy uh type of movie
but when you're looking at what he just
said here you know people want to be
entertained
that's why people check out to go see a
movie because they want to be
entertaining they want to check out of
the current reality
and i think with with the platform that
i've seen and to see what happened to
uh kevin hart a few years ago because he
was he was taken out because of tweets
he did
12 years ago when he is a comedian
and just to see what these type of
things have got we haven't watched
anything on sunday nights for
a very long time outside the fact that
we do conference calls on sunday nights
but there's no desire for me to want to
be able to break out from my current
schedule versus spending time my family
or
our business and want to say i want to
watch these awards
do you agree with uh mr donald trump i
agree with mr matt sapaula that's my guy
right there
uh do i agree with trump i think look
whether i agree with trump well i don't
watch the oscars so let me just say that
but look where trump's mind is at right
now he's not worried about trade he's
not worrying about policies he's not
worried about
climate but this is part of word about
the oscars no he's not worried about us
what about the where do
if that's what you took from it you're
the kind of person that when you read
scripture you need 15 people to
translate it for you because
you may interpret can any of you guys
read hebrew i can read him did he
actually read it yeah i can read
honestly you can read it i can't
seriously did you watch passion in
christ uh
with mel gibson yeah i did did you you
know there was
did you understand the language or no i
can't speak hebrew i could read it
but was it i could read it i can't
understand the language there's a
difference
i thought was spoken in aramaic i was
yeah that wasn't it
it was that that's not it was aramaic
and assyrian but
kai wants to say something go ahead i
think there's obviously one notable
thing to mention as well is
what movies really came out last year i
think that's a big thing for
obviously the oscars have been going
downwards but a big part of it is what
movies came out last year
so i got a question for you say no
movies came out last year but kevin hart
was hosting would you tune in
say no movies came out last year but
elon musk was hosting would you tune in
say no movie no good movies came out
last year but ricky your race is hosting
would you tune in
say no good movies came out last year
but dave chappelle is hosting would you
tune in come on
say no more you understand what i'm
saying absolutely good movies came out a
good
host makes a show this is why people
spend money to bring a great host to any
event
and mmc makes a concert and emcee makes
a wedding
you've been to a wedding where the mc is
like okay make some noise for uh the the
bride and the groom okay awesome all
right
all right everybody get up and let me
tell you we got them coming up here you
know
family on the left right right oh my
gosh what's going on with this guy you
ever gotten up you're like what's going
on with this host
kind of makes you move we went to a uh
new year's
uh uh uh persian new year party at our
friend's house nader okay
just met nato very i love this guy man
it's just a classic guy
and we're there at his house in uh south
florida
south florida beautiful home harbor ride
the whole anyways
and we're you know standing around it's
me my wife she's pregnant she has
no desire to stand up and i said babe
we're gonna stay for one hour we'll
leave at 10 30. i promise you we left at
2 o'clock in the morning
next thing you know music is playing all
this stuff
they bring these four dancers girls four
dancers what do they do
they're the ones that come and grab your
hands and we're running jennifer's like
dude i'm pregnant
jennifer is dancing persian music i'm
dancing persian music because somebody's
livening up the place right
now imagine if that wasn't there you're
not dancing that night i tell you i'm
not dancing that night if they don't
bring me out
you need a good host so yes even though
we didn't have any good movies a host
would have changed the show
you were going to say something no i was
i was wondering if you were doing the uh
yes well i'll tell you one quick story
uh i was at
uh a wedding this was probably at what
age did all your friends start getting
married what age
late twenties early thirties okay late
twenties right okay so one of my friends
who's my college roommate shout out to
nicorito if he's watching this right now
uh he's just a wedding crasher story or
i was invited although i have crashed
many a weddings
but he was like one of our first friends
to get married i think we were like 27
years old
he ironically married a girl from san
antonio so everyone flew to senate we're
all broke we got no one's got money
you're 26 27 years old no one's got
money
so he's got no money we're all getting
married this guy's getting married or no
they're all like we're we all go to the
wedding yeah
you know we're staying at the la quinta
it's nothing fancy whatsoever
you know he didn't have a band he had
like a one san antonio mexican dj
present play this guy did not have the
it factor
at all it was a cash bar like come on
like again just very low budget wedding
and i mean by by 11 o'clock people are
like dude this is the worst one
okay ever like people are like adam you
gotta get on the mic
you gotta you go and i was doing
stand-up comedy this time they're like
dude you gotta you gotta go do something
bro like the guy
this guy's wedding's the worst so i i go
up to the dj who
basically he was the dj and the the
microphone i was like hey buddy you mind
if i
take the mic and take over he goes
please like gives me
the bro i go i go all right put this
song on uncle luca go everybody
circle up circles up and i just
completely hyped this party and i'm like
grandma get your ass on the dance floor
grandma's okay like
i got the bachelor and i'm freaking the
grandma i'm getting the bridesmaids
going on
but i hyped it up so what you are saying
is maybe i do agree with donald trump
you got to get a good host yeah you
forget the party there it is i came full
circle
i think i think this is important i
think what i really took away by what
you just saw what you just said right
now
is the oscars should hire you next year
i think you're applying for something
i'd hype it up you're applying forward
to the left i call out the right
there you go okay by the way last point
yeah
the the wedding was supposed to end at
midnight we stayed till two in the
morning i believe you that we freaked
out
you're a hype guy though you're a good
host you're a hype guy yes
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye